I went to Romania and guy came up to me
with tears in his eyes and and he says
thank you jr. for for saving Romania the
oil and sex soap TV show Dallas is back
on the small screen the unapologetically
odious jr. the unappealing Lea ethical
Bobby and the uncontrollably alcoholic
Sue Ellen are all back along with the
new crew of young hard-bodied hotties to
pull in viewers who have yet to start
pulling in social security checks during
its original run from 1978 to 1991
Dallas was an international cultural
phenomenon with ratings higher than late
seventies interest rates
it was the most or second most watched
show in the United States for half a
decade showing up in Abbas songs and
Ozzy Osbourne videos and spinning off
the mega hit Knott's landing but
Dallas's greatest impact ultimately
wasn't in these United States but in
communist Romania where it helped topple
a brutal regime Dallas was the last
western show allowed during the
nightmarish 1980s because President
Nikola
hska thought it showcased all that was
wrong with capitalism in fact the show
provided a luxuriant alternative to a
communism that was forcing people to
wait more than a decade to buy the most
rattletrap
Iron Curtain cars I think we were
directly or indirectly responsible for
the fall of communism Larry Hagman told
The Associated Press a decade ago they
would see the wealthy Ewings and say hey
we don't have all this stuff after the
dictator and his wife were shot in
Christmas Eve 1989 the pilot episode of
Dallas with a previously censored sex
scene spliced back in was one of the
first foreign shows broadcast on
liberated Romanian TV the impact of
Dallas on global world views reminds us
that vulgar popular culture is every bit
as important as chin stroke and
political discourse in fomenting real
social change throw away cultural
products influence far-flung societies
in ways that are impossible for anyone
even dictators to predict or control
that lesson is more relevant than ever
in a world where movies TV shows of
music crossed borders with impunity and
the free West engages the semi-free East
whether in China or Iraq
if the United States is interested in
spreading American values and
institutions TV shows may go a lot
further than armored personnel carriers
like Mikhail Gorbachev poodle hair cuts
and Members Only jackets Dallas didn't
long survive the post-cold war world and
helped create it's more like an
uncontainable gusher in a Texas oil
field that original series left us far
richer than we ever dreamed possible for
reason TV I'm Nicholas
you